today on the Matt Walsh show
pro-abortion activists are gloating
today because of a documentary that
allegedly shows a prominent pro-life
activist confessing quote/unquote on her
deathbed that she was paid by the
pro-life cabal to pretend to be pro-life
we'll take a look at this story there's
a lot there's a lot of questions are
raised there's a lot of reason to be
skeptical and we'll talk about that also
five headlines including Planned
Parenthood apparently stealing stimulus
money that was supposed to go to small
businesses plus our daily cancellation
and some of your emails much more all of
that coming up but first a word from our
good friends at noon you know in my
experience one-size-fits-all approaches
just don't work at all in any facet of
life I mean you look even at one size
fits all clothing none of that stuff
ever fits me I'm a very oddly shaped
sort of person I discovered and so if
it's one size fits all it won't fit
that's especially true when it comes to
fitness and health and diet and exercise
with all the diet and exercise noise out
there how do you know which one works
for you you decide what your goals are
that's what it should be a new Miz going
to help you reach them this is not a one
size fits all this is a a personalized
thing that's going to work specifically
for you new Miz not a diet it's a
healthy and easy to stick to way of life
that's been my experience with it
certainly is that it's that's the main
thing it's you can actually stick to it
you can form those good habits makes a
lot easier to form those habits you know
we're all strapped for time we don't
have all the time we want and that's why
if you can only commit 10 minutes a day
then that's what it'll be and noon will
make that work join the new community
now pair up with a virtual coach to plan
your strategy to reach your goals your
personal coach and the noon community
are there to keep you in check and also
to inspire you along the way so shut off
all the noise and sign up for your trial
today at n om dot-com / Walsh get
personalized guidance at noon comm slash
Walsh that's n oom dot-com / Walsh ok
let's talk about this
60 million well and one we'll start with
this 60 million human beings have been
slow
by abortion since it was legalized in
this country it's it's no surprise that
these supporters of this massacre would
lack ethical scruples to put it mildly
which is why you know I was disgusted
but certainly not surprised or shocked
at all by this article in The Daily
Beast gloating about a documentary that
supposedly shows Jane Roe of roe v wade
confessing on her deathbed that her
pro-life conversion was an act that she
put on for money now backing up for just
a moment
this is Norma McCorvey aka Jane Roe she
was a she was the woman at the the
center of the infamous legal case that
led to abortion being legalized across
the country because the Supreme Court
somehow discovered within the
Constitution this mythical right to an
abortion actually they found the
mythical right to an abortion by first
locating the mythical right to privacy
which is that which is which is also not
in the Constitution and so and from
there they got to the right to abortion
just a horrible legal decision that even
if you're in favor of abortion if you're
an honest person you would have to look
at that legal decision and agree that
there are a lot of problems with it well
it's well known the mcore that McCourty
later in life had a change of heart and
became an outspoken and prominent
pro-life activist for many years okay so
this wasn't like something that happened
in the last six months of her life this
was for many years in the later stage of
her life she was a pro-life activist and
this fact has always been a source of
heartburn for pro-abortion activists who
were quite upset that they couldn't
continue using her to keep abortion
legal the way that they had used her to
get it illegal to get it legal in the
first place but it seems that they found
a way to manipulate and exploit her
again even in death so according to The
Daily Beast this upcoming FX documentary
titled aka Jane Roe will show McCorvey
shortly before her death in a nursing
home in 2017
claiming that her pro-life conversion
was all an act
she was acting the whole time and
supposedly she admits that pro-life
operatives paid her to lie for 20 years
and pretend to be pro-life this of
course supposed revelation has been met
with all of the grotesque bragging and
football spiking that you would expect
from people who again support and
applaud the mass butcher of children
including and many people many pro bortz
have jumped in on this including
Alexander Kaiser Cortez sent out a tweet
just thrilled with it and using this as
an occasion to attack quote-unquote
right-wingers and so on and so forth but
there is good reason to be extremely
skeptical mccorvey was an elderly woman
hooked up to an oxygen tank in a nursing
home at the time this documentary was
filmed I haven't seen the documentary
yet nobody hasn't come out yet but she
was an elderly woman hooked up to a
nurse she was in a nursing home oxygen
tank and then the director the director
of the documentary Nick Sweeney shows up
to interview her now we should note that
Sweeney is a far left radical whose
previous films include a BBC special
celebrating transgender children in fact
let me show you the preview a little
clip of that documentary just so you can
get you get a feel for this guy Nick
Sweeney and what he's all about so just
go ahead and watch this the medicine is
so that she doesn't go through male
puberty you know one step closer to
being like a full woman
how do you make these kinds of decisions
twelve year old kids it can be stir all
and rips the heart of you sometimes I
think is it the right thing to be
transgender should I just be a boy
should I just not be Who I am
[Music]
I just eat if they hate me
I'm not changing Who I am and becoming
Who I am isn't that great you got a boy
they're being drugged by his mother
chemically castrated you know Nick
Sweeney's filming it and it's a
inspirational music in the background
this is somebody with an agenda this is
a fight like I said a far left radical
with an agenda talking to an old dying
and clearly troubled woman that's the
context so more context another figure
who features prominently apparently in
the documentary is a guy named Reverend
Rob Schenck and he's an evangelical
minister who had his own conversion
experience several years ago except in
this case it was the opposite he went
from being a pro-life activist to a
staunch defender of abortion and right
now
he's and he continues to be a minister
quote/unquote but now he's against
overturning roe v wade he says that
overturning roe v wade would cause chaos
and pain this is a minister saying this
and he's another guy that's involved in
this documentary it's interviewed in the
documentary so it's a reiterate this is
not an objective piece of work
dispassionately documenting an old
woman's honest confession this is
far-left propaganda and so the
appropriate portions of salt must be
taken alongside it it's important to
realize that mccorvey pro-life
transition happened over the course of
several years okay if she was acting
then this was method acting that would
put Daniel day-lewis to shame this is
this is I mean this would be someone who
spent years and years developing her act
and keeping it going even in private
because many people who knew McCorvey
personally have come forward to say that
she spoke passionately about her
pro-life convictions in private all the
time so was was that all part of her act
or maybe these people are in on the
conspiracy I don't know
speaking of conspiracies who are these
nefarious pro-lifers who conspired with
McCorvey to pretend to be pro-life for
20 years I have been in the pro-life
movement myself for many years and I'm
not aware of any
smokey backrooms where these kinds of
plots are hatched now it's possible that
I've never been invited to them or maybe
I'm in on it and I'm just saying it for
that reason maybe I'm being paid to who
knows
in fact The Daily Beast even mentions
that McCorvey is part of her conversion
to Catholicism which coincided with her
conversion to being pro-life I mean all
of this came together she eventually
broke off her romantic relationship with
another with another woman that she was
having she she struggled with same-sex
attraction for her entire life and The
Daily Beast even says that she talked
about this struggle in quote anguished
interviews so was that all an act - I
mean did this woman dedicate decades of
her life to some sort of bizarre
conservative satire act is that what
this is that's what you would have to
believe in order to take the deathbed
confessions story at face value
McCrory would have had to have lied
about almost everything to almost
everyone for decades and for what some
money from a non-existent pro-life
conspiratorial cabal you know I mean the
thing is if if this was someone who's
just a mercenary in it for money then
she could have made a lot more as a
pro-abortion figurehead I mean if that's
what this was about she made a she made
a pretty serious miscalculation Planned
Parenthood gute mocker Institute you
know now nay RAL these are pro-abortion
organizations that have a lot of money
to throw around and they've got a lot
more money to throw around than pro-life
organizations do I can tell you that
right now
so if if she was just in it for the
money then she didn't need to fake being
pro-life to make money off the abortion
issue and she could have done it on the
other side and made a lot more so the
whole idea is just plainly absurd well
then what do we make of this claim that
she apparently made on film that she was
acting the whole time it was paid off
well I don't know maybe it's true you
know maybe Jane Roe Norma Cobra mccorvey
was a very dedicated performance artist
it's possible or maybe she was a
confused old woman being manipulated by
pro-abortion activists that also I think
is very possible and quite a bit more
possible or maybe some other explanation
now who knows of course in the end none
of this has any effect on the reality of
abortion whether she was really pro-life
or not and I think she was it doesn't
have any effect on whether abortion is
right or wrong and of course it is wrong
because the reality of abortion is what
I said at the top it is an act of
violence against the innocent and sixty
million innocents have died because of
it whatever Norma McCorvey did or didn't
think abortion is a hideous evil and the
transparent attempt to exploit an old
woman who is now dead and unavailable
for comment
is also hideously evil but these people
will just stop at nothing one other
point about about this that I was just
thinking about you know when you talk
about deathbed conversions or
confessions one or the other usually
people on the Left are very skeptical of
these kinds of stories because you hear
them a lot on the other side so just one
example I would I would give you a
philosopher by the name of Anthony flue
who's who died a few years ago and he
was an atheist philosopher very
outspoken atheist for many many years
well towards the end of his life in the
last couple of years of his life he
converted and and and in wrote a book
saying that there is a God now he wasn't
he didn't he what he didn't become a
Christian you know he didn't believe in
the Abrahamic God he became basically a
deist but still really significant and
like I said you published it wasn't just
a documentary he published an entire
book laying out his arguments well at
the time many atheists and you know not
everyone that's an atheist is on the
left but there's a lot of crossover
there of course many atheists refuse to
believe it and in fact there was an
entire
very long lengthy article written and I
think the New York New York magazine New
York Times magazine claiming or arguing
that this conversion was false and that
he was an old man his mental faculties
declining and he was manipulated by by
by Christians by evangelicals who you
know took advantage of the fact that he
was basically senile and that was the
claim and there are a lot of atheists
who said that about Anthony flow I don't
know if that's true or not and in fact I
read his book I believe the book is
called why there is a God you know and I
have to admit that I was it even struck
me as a little bit weird because this
was a you know a very intelligent
philosopher very rigorous philosophical
mind I'd read some of his atheist work
that he'd done and then I read his book
this dramatic conversion or not really
conversion but a change of mind and it
wasn't as philosophically rigorous as I
would have thought that it would have
been and so it did strike me as a little
bit strange I'm not saying that I think
he was manipulated by dastardly
Christians who convinced them yeah I
don't know I don't know what happened
but it did it did strike me that this is
a guy lived his whole life was very
articulate in his defense of an idea
that I happen to disagree with and then
at the very end of his life while his
you know potentially his mentally
faculties are declining he has this
change of mind and and then he dies but
on that you know you've got a theist
saying I don't know if I buy it even
though he said it I don't know if I buy
it it seems like there's something else
going on here
maybe there was maybe there wasn't well
now we look at this and just watches a
lot of those same people are gonna take
it at face value and say oh well she
said it so that's it you see this proves
not only was she a pro-abortion the
entire time but approve something about
the pro-life movement that the pro-life
movement is some sort of as I said cuz
conspiratorial regime that pays people
to pretend to be pro-life alright
so double standards all over the place
let's go to headlines number one staying
on the theme for a moment thirty-seven
Planned Parenthood affiliates filed
for a combined 80 million dollars in
loans from the Paycheck protection
program during the corona virus they did
actually receive the money now the
government says they want the money back
this was all originally reported by
Tucker Carlson the Small Business
Administration is saying that they never
should have received any money or
applied for it because organizations
with over 500 employees don't don't
qualify because they're not small
businesses Planned Parenthood has
thousands of employees they're very far
from this is a billion-dollar
organization with thousands of employees
doesn't qualify as a small business and
Planned Parenthood would have known this
of course they knew what the rules were
I knew what the rules were just from
following the news so this would seem to
be a deliberate attempt to scam the
system which is no surprise coming from
Planned Parenthood and this is what I
was trying to say about the McCrory
thing you have to understand that
abortion activists people in the
abortion industry are extraordinarily
dishonest all the time you cannot trust
a word they say about anything they just
lie lie lie all the time and anyone with
any experience dealing with these people
knows this and here they are trying to
scam the system during a pandemic to
bilk millions of dollars out of the
government that should have gone to
small businesses they already get half a
billion dollars a year from the
government man that's not enough they
need another 80 million number - this
seems like pretty big news NASA
scientists may have discovered evidence
of a parallel universe where time runs
backwards kind of feels now like we're
living in that parallel universe maybe
the two of them urged or something The
Daily wire reports scientists at the
National Aeronautics Space
Administration have conducted a series
of cosmic ray detection experiments
which have found particles that could be
from outside the universe so quoting now
The Daily Star
NASA's Antarctic impulsive transient
antenna antenna uses a giant balloon to
halt delicate electronic antennas high
into the cold dry air above Antarctica
where there is little or no radio noise
to distort the findings there is a
constant wind of high-energy particles
come
from outerspace some of which are
millions of times more powerful than
anything we generate ourselves low
energy particles neutrinos can pass
completely through the earth barely
interacting with the substance of our
planet at all but higher energy
particles are stopped by the
reassuringly solid matter of Earth that
means that high-energy particles can
only be detected coming down from outer
space to detect a heavier particle a Tau
neutrino coming up out of the earth
would imply that these particles are
actually traveling backwards in time and
that is exactly what the Anita
scientists have said the findings
suggest evidence of a parallel universe
okay does that make sense it does to me
I mean I understood everything I just
read there okay basically to recap the
the high-energy thingies are doing
something okay and and there's this big
balloon that you know is involved and
anyway then we discovered a parallel
universe so that's just breaking it down
in layman's terms pretty big news number
three and Michigan's governor governor
Caron also known as Gretchen Whitmer
he's in talks to be Joe Biden's vice
president apparently she revealed that
on the Today Show and talking about it
publicly was of course her way of
angling for the role now this is really
something else Whitmer is quite possibly
the most hated woman in America right
now I can't think of who would beat her
for that for that trophy I mean maybe
Nancy Pelosi I don't know but I think no
right now it's Whitmer so Biden is
considering bringing on board has taken
a woman who is so despised that there
had been protests against her in her
home state like every day for two months
brilliant so it's either it's either her
or Stacey Abrams Stacey Abrams a woman
with no political talent no achievements
of any kind so those are that's what
we've narrowed it down to those two if I
were a woman which I could be you know
you never know I would feel pretty
insulted right now that Biden has
committed himself to picking a woman
which is already stupid and patronizing
enough
and these are the two that he's
narrowing it down to you you really
couldn't I mean you literally couldn't
pick worse candidates than these two
number four but I think it's a great
idea let me just say I and I hope that
Biden picks courage and whitmer number
four and an update on this important
story as we covered yesterday Nancy
Pelosi said that Trump is a is morbidly
obese we talked about that yesterday
well Trump responded as we knew he would
by saying that Pelosi has mental
problems and now Pelosi has come back
and said that Trump is too sensitive and
I can't even talk keep talking about
this good lord we are governed by sixth
graders this is what this is what
political disputes have come down to
your fat know what your crazy
stop being sensitive I'm telling mommy
you know it can be interesting to go
back and read for example the
lincoln-douglas debates in 1958 or
whatever the was or read about you know
we just read in general about the
disputes between politicians 100 years
ago 150 years ago and you see that there
was you know often often very intense
disputes and exchanges obviously I mean
we fought a war over some of those
disputes and 600,000 people died so this
whole idea that politics are more
partisan more divided more more hostile
now than they've ever been
that of course is crazy this this is
child's play in more ways than one
compared to what it's been in the past
but when you read some of this stuff
there was an eloquence and an
intelligence and a depth there even in
dispute where now it's gone - you're fat
no you're crazy okay number five a
Kentucky convenience store landed itself
in hot water when a sign posted on the
window went viral the sign says here's
what the sign says or said rather
because it's been taken down no face
masks allowed in the store lower your
mask or go somewhere else stop listening
to Bashir he's a dummy Bashir's the
governor
now I love that sign personally and you
know because I'm a 6th grader - so now
someone posted this to Facebook
explicitly to shame the business for
putting the sign up and eventually the
business owner relented somewhat and
said that ok he's not gonna turn you
away if you have a mask but you don't
have to wear one this goes back to what
I've been saying about the mask issue
which is I think it should be totally up
to the business their property their
rules that's my take on it if if this
business owner doesn't want face masks
that should be his right don't like it
go somewhere else like the sign says he
should have as much a right to require
that you not wear face masks as any
other business should have to require
that you do wear face masks and the
thing is it's it's not like there isn't
a very logical reason to ban face masks
just if you want to go to Google and
Google surgical masks and theft or
surgical masks and robbery and you'll
see tons of recent examples of people
who have taken advantage of the face
mask policies to rob stores or shoplift
or steal and of course that's gonna
happen I think about this every time I
go into a store now and everybody is in
a disguise oK you've got everybody in
the store is in a disguise this has to
be hell on earth for loss prevention
departments how are they supposed to
what are they supposed to do how are
they supposed to stop people from
stealing yeah I mean we have we have
it's it's as if we have turned off all
the security cameras in every store in
America that's the effect because
everybody's in masks and there's also no
uniformity to the masks so I've seen
people walking in with like you know
motorcycle helmets on or you know I mean
we've all seen this um a lot of people
just with bandanas around their face
literally like stagecoach robbers
they're walking in the stores and those
bandanas by the way you've got a bandana
tied around your face and it's like
hanging down like this right you know
like the classic bank robber or
stagecoach robber
that's gonna that's a very good way to
disguise your idea
but what the hell is that going to do to
stop a virus from getting it I mean
you've got you've got all this area
right down here but the thing is just
hanging down airflow is not restricted
at all so I don't know how that's
supposed to stop you from getting the
virus or from transmitting it it doesn't
seem like there's that's gonna have any
effect whatsoever but again it is a good
disguise and so this is what stores are
dealing with and that's why companies
should be allowed to make their own
decisions you know about about there's
there a lot of risks that have to be
balanced now there's a risk of the
corona virus yeah but then there's also
the risk of having a bunch of people in
disguises in your store able to steal
you know want to win okay let's go to
your daily cancellation now for daily
cancellation we're canceling any and all
Democrats who use phrases like believe
in science and for the latest example
here's Joe Biden on Twitter he says we
need a president who believes in science
very simple and that's got you know over
280,000 likes people cheering it on yes
believe in science now I agree with the
sentiment my issue is not with the
sentiment itself I I you know I I don't
want someone running the country who
doesn't believe in science but the
problem is that the guy saying this Joe
Biden is a Democrat and what that means
is that he believes a man can get
pregnant and that women have penises and
that a human being five seconds before
birth is not a person and potentially
isn't even a human okay that's what he
believes and we know that any Democrat
on the national stage and almost any
Democrat anywhere national stage or not
believes all of those things I just
listed or at least will pretend to
believe them will claim that they
believe them and you know you're
entitled
those beliefs you're entitled to
embarrass yourself by going around
saying it but you're not entitled to
pretend that you support science these
people think that men can get pregnant
and they still have the have the cojones
pun intended to go around claiming that
they believe inside this is the most
anti site the modern Democratic Party is
the most anti science political party in
American history bar none okay there
have been different anti or non
scientific notions that have been
popular throughout throughout history
but nothing like this in fact you could
go back even to ancient times when
people knew almost nothing about the
world you know they thought that the Sun
orbits the earth that there was only one
solar system in the whole universe you
know maybe some of them thought the
earth was flat so on and so forth they
thought that there were like demons
under the ground shaking the earth
during an earthquake all of that and
they could be excused for thinking all
that because they didn't have modern
science didn't have the tools that we
have even they knew that men can't get
pregnant they knew that much at least
now in modern times we have all the
scientific tools at our disposal and now
we have this this insanely anti
scientific notion that has taken hold
the mainstream of the Democratic Party
and if you're going to say that then you
can't pretend to support science and it
just it continues to amaze me although
it shouldn't that we have these
prominent politicians who believe again
that men can get pregnant and they're
never asked about it they are never even
asked to explain that point of view to
justify it to explain how they arrived
at that point of it never asked I mean
not once I I haven't seen it at one
debate just posing it to the Democrats
so you believe men can get pregnant tell
me about that that's all just set them
up and and I
I want I want to hear one of these
people just give me give me like two
minutes on that just talk about that
idea of men getting pregnant for two
minutes explain that I don't even need
to follow up I just need the original
they're not asked but of course because
of course they can't be just it can't be
justified and the media knows that
that's why they don't ask it but that's
why they can't claim to believe in
science so all of that is canceled
we're gonna go finally to emails and you
can email the show if we come in daily
why remember have access to the mailbag
let's go to this email from Daniel says
dear Matt I understand you keep bees and
your wife is a chicken farmer which
means you both have hobbies you also
have a huge family how do you guys do it
my wife and I dated for four years
before we were married and now we have a
perfectly healthy one-year-old that we
love with all of our hearts since our
son was born there has been new conflict
between us I was in a band for years
when we were dating and had to give that
up when our son was born it bothered my
wife that I left once a week to rehearse
I travel a lot for work as well so I
agreed that a band was just too much to
take on at this time it was a hard
choice for me to make but it was a
logical decision to quit especially
because we have conflicting work
schedules podcasting is something I've
always wanted to do and I figured I
could do it from home I asked my wife
for a few hours once a week to prepare
and record episodes she first agreed but
backpedals when I take her up on her
word I feel like I can't have a hobby at
all and I have always been someone that
feels the need to create art music or
comedy doesn't matter my wife doesn't
have any hobbies the way she sees it the
baby is the only thing that matters what
should I do am i selfish for wanting me
time it's hard not to feel guilty about
my wants when it seems my wife doesn't
even need her alone time it's a
confusing time for me okay Daniel well
no you're not selfish
I'm sure your wife is feeling
overwhelmed right now which is
understandable you guys are pretty new
to the parenting gig and congratulations
by the way on the baby but trust me in
the long run she'll be happy if you have
interests and hobbies and talents that
you've cultivated it makes you a more
interesting person
it makes you happier it makes you more
well-rounded and those are all things
that wives appreciate in their husbands
and husbands and their wives and people
in people generally so this is
not a selfish pursuit I think in the
long run you know she she if because
she's overwhelmed right now she's trying
to stop you from from having other
interests I think in the long run she
would regret that now the truth is if
I'm just being frag about it that your
wife based on if you have presented it
in an accurate way okay which I'm not
accusing you of lying but then again you
know in in disputes people can sometimes
tend to see it their own way not the
other person's way but if the way you're
presenting it is completely accurate
then your wife is the one being selfish
right now okay
if it's true that she doesn't want you
to do anything or have any fun outside
of being with her and the kid then yes
that is certainly selfish and you should
communicate that you know maybe not in
the way that I am right now but in your
own way so if I were you I would say
something like listen honey I need to
have some time to myself to do these
things that I enjoy and are important to
me I'm gonna take that time because
there's no reason that I shouldn't okay
so I'm just I'm gonna do it I will be
more than happy to give you your own
time as well I think you need to have
some time to it I will be more than
happy to make sure that you get that
time also but I'm gonna take the time so
you know I'm just I'm a big believer
being honest in a marriage I'm also a
big believer in spouses giving each
other time to themselves to pursue their
own interests and be their own people
you know I think that's really important
and I'm always kind of shocked when I
see these marriages where that doesn't
happen which I guess is kind of common I
suppose so that's my take on it and by
the way the idea that you can't play
music because you have a kid is pretty
crazy in my view I mean why shouldn't
you like I've mentioned before one of my
other hobbies is fishing I like to fish
and I've talked to many guys who will
say about fish a guy I loved doing that
before I got married before I had kids
but of course now that I have kids I
can't do it anymore
or you know and you hear that about
insert any other hobby fishing brewing
beer playing basketball playing music
whatever it is and you hear that and I
think well what do you mean you can't do
it anymore neither yet
why can't you I mean just because you
have kids doesn't mean literally every
single second of the day that you're not
working you have to spend watching the
kids like there are two of you in the
marriage it's one of the advantages of
having a marriage and so there's
absolutely no reason why you guys can't
give each other breaks and you should do
it one for your own sanity and to also
two so that you can pass these interests
and passions on to your kids you know if
you and that's one thing about about one
one difference I've noticed about men
and women in men and women is that you
know women will tend to do things with
the kids that the kids enjoy which is
great you know a kid a woman is gonna
get down on the kids level and play
games with them that they enjoy which is
which and kids need that which is why
they need a mom dads are more likely to
incorporate a kid into something that we
enjoy and I think kids also need that
and so if you like to fish then you're
gonna bring the kid fishing the kids
gonna become and is gonna get better at
that and gonna like that if you like
music then you incorporate the kid your
child in that and and and your child
will become a great musician in short
time because you are and that's that's a
one of the blessings and gifts that you
can give your kid but you have to
maintain your own interests and
cultivate your own skills and talents so
that you can pass that on to your kid
that's one of the advantages of doing
that so that's my take on that all right
from Shalom says my future dictator and
saver I saw a speech of yours on YouTube
in the video it looks like you're
sweating and the audience are trying to
cool themselves down I just want to know
what's the story behind this and what
will their will there be any punishment
when your day of glory comes yes I've
got so many questions about this over
the last year there is a YouTube video
of me out there
sweating profusely more than normal or
I'm getting a speech just like pouring
sweat okay
and that was my speech at Baylor last
year some people may remember even
though Baylor's a Christian University
there was a lot of pushback and me going
to the university a lot of people didn't
want me there especially it seems like
the powers that be in the university
didn't want me there some of the
students didn't want me there
I showed up anyway I gave the speech it
was a great turnout but they never
turned on the AC in the room it was
blistering out I was like 85 degrees in
their small room in Texas okay I think
it was in May and and he had all these
people packed in there no a/c is turned
on and so it's really hot and yeah I'm
just like sweating through the entire
thing everybody else in the room is
sweating too now I wouldn't necessarily
claim that this was a deliberate thing
the university did except for the fact
that as soon as my speech ended the AC
kicked back on I mean my speech ended
and with the speech of qat as an hour no
AC speech ends I'm walking out and boom
the AC kicks on so yes I believe that it
was deliberate I have enough experience
with these universities and giving
speeches to no deliberate stuff when I
see it because very often is like this
is weird coincidence where if I'm going
to a university and there's pushback and
I hear that the university doesn't want
me there very often when I get there
there are all these weird little things
that go wrong this is a what a strange
quiz is like I went to Notre Dame and
weirdly enough the university couldn't
find a microphone for me on the entire
campus couldn't find him there was no
microphone available on the entire
campus that night how strange you know
and so I had to give the speech to like
you know again a big crowd in a room no
microphone I had to shout the entire
thing so but you know you you power
through it anyway and these are just
petty little things that people do
finally is this from Taylor says hi Matt
thank you for the show I just want to
say that I agree with you about the
left's double standard but honestly Tara
Reid does not seem credible to me and
some of the things that have come out
about her do make me question her claims
I hate Joe Biden as much as the next
conservative but I think he's being
unfairly targeted here and we shouldn't
go along with it
yeah I I think that there's plenty of
reasons to doubt Tara Reid starting with
as I said yesterday and as I've said all
along that the very fact that someone is
coming out
thirty years later 25 years later
however long it's been you know decades
later never said this publicly finally
comes out in the middle of a political
campaign or in the middle of a Supreme
Court hearing or as soon as this person
whoever it is is is all over the news
now you come out and say hey by the way
they rate me 30 years ago doesn't mean
it's not true but that alone his reason
to be skeptical so I agree with you
there and then you read all this other
stuff and some of her former co-workers
have come out and said that you know and
and and and said basically she's she was
terminally dishonest and all these other
things yeah I think all that stuff is
relevant in evaluating these claims it
goes to her credibility so I think there
is reason to be skeptical however you
say that Joe Biden is being unfairly
targeted I don't think it is unfair in
his case and I'll tell you why because
this is his own standard I don't think
it could be unfair to apply someone's
own standard back to them he is the one
who said believe all women or okay maybe
that wasn't his exact phrase because we
learned this yesterday we have to be
specific what he said his exact wording
was that when a woman makes a claim we
should start with the assumption that
the essence of what she's saying is true
that's what he said okay which in other
words believe women well that was his
standard and he said that in reference
to Kavanagh and we know the reason he
said it was just because he was trying
to tear down Kavanagh he was taking part
in the in the Kavanagh lynch mob so we
know that's why he said it but that was
the standard that he set and so to apply
that back to him I think is is complete
I think that's the essence of fairness
now I don't think that that's the way it
should work in a court of law so you
know if this were to get into the courts
which it never will I think the
presumption of innocence obviously still
applies but just in terms of the peanut
gallery evaluating this no sorry I'm not
gonna yeah I mean I'm not gonna pretend
that I that I think this is Andriy
percent true I'm not gonna lie
out of myself and be dishonest the way
the Joe Biden is but am I gonna go to
the bat you can go to bat defending him
no why would I
he's the one who said he is the one who
said how he thinks these cases should be
viewed and so as far as I'm concerned
all right
I mean if I'll step back and let that
standard be applied to him because
that's what he said so no I think it
would be unfair actually I mean arguably
it's unfair to Joe Biden if he's the one
who said that you know he thinks we
should give the benefit of the doubt to
the woman what he wants we can't turn
around to give him the benefit of the
doubt that's disrespectful to his wishes
and I'm being facetious of course but I
think you know if a person ends up
following on they're falling on their
own sword to get a dose of their own
medicine I don't see that as unfair you
know I see it as sort of a cosmic
justice but of course there's not gonna
be any cosmic justice in this case
because he's not gonna have his own
standard applied back to him because of
the double standard on the left and so
he's gonna you know he he has survived
this fine and I think it's it's not
gonna really have any effect if Joe
Biden loses in the general election
which i think is a very good chance he
will it will it will be because he's a
senile man losing his mind and people
are uncomfortable with that which really
putting everything else aside that's
enough reason to not vote for him thanks
for the email and we will wrap it up
there thanks for watching everybody have
a great day Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
our supervising producers are Mathis
Glover and Robert Sterling our technical
producer is Austin Stevens edited by
Dani D'Amico and our audio is mixed by
Robyn Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20
hospitals are empty homeless shelters
are empty coronavirus cases aren't
spiking great news right not according
to the mainstream media which is working
hard at inventing fake problems to
frighten us then the high school science
experiment that locked down the world
Joe Biden's new nickname for president
Trump spoiler alert it's super lame and
an explosive new allegation that Norma
McCorvey the pro-abortion plaintiff in
Roe vs. Wade
faked her pro-life Christian conversion
all that more check it out on the
Michael Moore Show
[Music]